another Progressive value of the day is
outright lying about everything here's
Democrat leader Hakeem Jeffries saying
Republicans don't want kids to learn
about the Holocaust extreme Mega
Republicans don't want the Children of
America to learn about
the Holocaust
no like not true that's not in any bill
it's being taught in every single state
in America Most states have laws
requiring that the Holocaust be taught
but this is what they do they try to
scare the hell out of you about
everything absolutely everything so we
thought
I said Phoenix can we actually tell the
people what's in this parental rights
and education Bill we've already been
through this with hb1557 in Florida
which they call don't say gay even
though the word gay was an idiot but I
thought okay this is a bill that could
be going Nationwide could we get some
facts on that and he said yes yes we can
so we've got some info from the daily
wire the House of Representatives in a
virtually straight party line vote
passed the parents Bill of Rights uh the
parent sorry the parents Bill of Rights
bill on Friday Democrats unanimously
oppose the measure they were joined by
five Republicans the bill states that
parents should have the right to review
and make copies of at no cost the
curriculum of their child's school which
should be publicly available the right
to a list of books and other reading
materials available in the library of
their child's School the right to
inspect such books or other reading
materials and the right to know of a
School employee or contractor asks to
change a minor child's gender markers
pronouns or preferred name or allow a
child to change the child's sex-based
accommodations including locker rooms or
bathrooms you guys really need to
understand this
they are the ones that fear transparency
the bill is just so that you as a parent
would know what your kid is learning you
know anyone that's been to college you
get a syllabus at the beginning of the
year right and in that syllabus it says
here's what we're going to learn over
the course of the next six months here
is the reading material here's the these
days the information maybe you're gonna
have to download or an app you're gonna
have to download here's what we're going
to be doing in this class they don't
hide that's college level they don't
hide that information and only parse it
out throughout the year in weird ways we
are talking about state employees with
kids that are four five six seven eight
years old and now they're pushing this
into high school and we can have an
honest debate about when or if sex and
gender and all those things should be
taught in high schools and who that
should be left up to and everything else
that's a separate debate here but the
simple absolutely simple truth is every
single Democrat just voted against the
parents of America that means that they
think that superintendents and school
boards and people who have nothing to do
with these kids other than in many cases
just there to indoctrinate them I mean
you've seen all these videos of teachers
that are that are outright saying they
are trying to indoctrinate these kids
and and change their thought processes
away from what their parents might want
they fear that they fear that the
parents might know what's going on
[Music]
foreign